[Music]
in not fair news oh no what is what is
fair I'd like to bet you're born and
it's not fair about death is fair that's
true is it not always some people are
murdered some people get to die in their
sleep
I'm not saying the way you die I'm
saying death in general you die and you
die you die that's it it's not fair not
fair some people do come back to life
some of us are born tall some people
born short some people born
if you eat things we get fatter it's not
fair we're not equal from the get yeah
which is the awesome we're [ __ ]
snowflakes that's right
I think I agree with it okay
submitted by was I hated it I loved it I
was good an Amazon courier who was
robbed got fired and was told to repay
the cost of the stolen items well let's
hear the false loss is fake yeah yeah
unless he stole unless he stole it gotta
steal it but Amazon's Jeff Bezos is the
richest man in the world
thank you we we do weird couple to the
food she says that to everyone I never
tell them you think it's so cute I'm
gonna look for videos of you saying that
[ __ ] and if I find them - nice swear to
that so this story is about Martin he's
20 years old I heard the same [ __ ]
intro world yeah it's like he is a
career for this delivery service who
also works with Amazon and so apparently
one day when he was trying to make his
deliveries someone approached him with
the gun told him to drop his wallet in
his cellphone
drop the van he did and then they ended
up getting the van and took off
damn they took everything it took the
whole van everything Wow yeah and then
so apparently they found the van and
then a couple of days later that's when
Martin ends up texting his bosses
this is a conversation he says any news
yet
the boss says morning morning we'll
check today and let you know and then he
says thank you and then again and
afternoon now he's saying any updates at
all and the boss says still waiting
police still waiting police to release
the van about work we will not use your
service anymore about your earning we
about your earning we have to wait to
see what will be the bill for the van
and for the parcels inside and you and
you receive the rest of his paycheck
holy shmow yeah the next thing Martines
nothing he has nothing yeah Martin says
oh it was found then and that's not
exactly fair on me I never asked to be
robbed just so you and Amazon are aware
I'm seeking legal advice on this matter
he says okay and then Martin says can't
see how I can be charged it sounds a
little shady now knowing I was robbed
anything could have happened to me what
if he had a knife what if he ran me over
totally unfair I've just found out the
van was recovered on the 28th and he
mused on the contents I eat my wallet or
is it all gone so that's pretty much the
story here that's a pretty cold damn
that baby could drive he looks shady to
me I'm [ __ ] gay he looks like a
criminal I love how we all do that you
know that's a pretty cold manager
whoever those yeah well Tex always tough
to he could have been very nice on the
day you know but Tex come off a little
very short though I know that's what it
seems cold yeah yeah man that was kind
of [ __ ] up because if one of my
employees got robbed I don't see myself
texting that way that's kind of weird
yeah and then days later and not even
tell them that hey we recovered the van
like zero communication yeah it seems
like he didn't like this guy the manager
didn't like this guy
yeah but Amazon's hard course [ __ ] oh
really yeah I've read some [ __ ] that's
crazy
like these cats they have to like
deliver five five thousand packages a
day or some [ __ ] like that not like that
it's hyperbole but I'm saying like it's
something some high number
and then sometimes like these drivers I
mean I saw one story where this lady
like pooping on somebody's lawn yeah I
saw well they poop in their truck - yeah
they [ __ ] in jars because they have
quotas they gotta mean girls gotta go
back to work a foot within 48 hours of
giving birth yeah whoa that's nice guys
get delivered for Christmas son you know
I'm saying like that's the kind of like
illegal like don't think they have to do
[ __ ] the same day but maybe they signed
us something get not old job get mature
their independent contractors maybe yeah
I don't know I think it's some [ __ ] like
that because that's what he says service
is assuming in California like it could
be another business in the UK oh okay
gotcha well-known of whack ass phones
are they using where the bubbles are
blue and yellow it looks like it's
that's what I'm assuming if I did read
this one [ __ ] about like a Amazon exec
or someone who was like leaving the
company and they had to write about how
crazy it was and how much they have a
huge turnover rate cuz people just can't
meet with the demands but I think that's
why Jeff bezels is the richest man in
the world now absolutely I mean dude he
ate he's eating target alive right he
ate Walmart already like killed all the
big-box guys like Macy's in city
circuits and he's [ __ ] over dude
hello you found a way to create a
Chinese illegal Chinese business he's
like Alibaba for the US yeah dude but
you know what I love Amazon so much I
love it
good because of Amazon I like to
interact with people I don't have to I
don't have to look a teller and I while
I like something for Nicky or some [ __ ]
look if I buy like a pair of [ __ ]
underwear for Nicky or something I don't
got to be like do these aren't for me or
swear to diseases
why would it tell her everything well I
don't know but I always do that no you
know what I reflexively do that like
that is a teller like it you're at the
bank buying underwear
I guess you what is it cashier I call
him hello there
what is your culture calm why I think I
would look at you weird culture week my
culture we call you and me we're gonna
have it out one day we call cut don't
was like sir you have to fill out a
deposit for him I don't need to know any
of it why are you bringing underwear bro
I was just at lush for you the other day
getting you [ __ ] soap or water for
your hair yes soap for your here also
known as shampoo it's a bar of soap pal
no no no no no no wait
oh is that what your culture calls it so
yeah we do actually do we do repair soap
no look it's a dry bar soap for your
hair explain that [ __ ] it's a shampoo
your hands wet and then you I kind of
like circle it on my head a little you
put the bar so [ __ ] yeah and you go like
what's a bar if it's a shampoo you don't
like you don't like [ __ ] squeeze no
no I like it this is just for travel so
it's it's dry when you're traveling with
it and you put in a tin she's in like
technology and then this is how they did
it in 1800s
okay it stays dry flat - like so you
just like you don't have to have a
bottle that can live a condition so my
bar mmm so you're using this at home see
no I know we're going to we're traveling
tomorrow lucky it's kind of [ __ ] what's
like Nikki's like oh I take dry showers
it's like [ __ ] you talking about so much
so and powder with a dry shampoo every
girl uses it no I don't call it a dress
that's convoluting my words because he
doesn't understand dry shampoo I don't
know are you making [ __ ] up she does
trust me she don't
yeah where the shell the shoes of these
terrible stray showers what can I have
in a place where I mean obviously we're
young
[Laughter]
have you taken a drug shower Joyetech
I've used dry shampoo dry shampoo yes
she takes - everybody uses dry shampoo
no you know what the [ __ ] he does though
what he [ __ ] away my ass real good for
you by the way he takes [ __ ] what do
they call peer INSAS he's I gotta take a
shower he's like that was just a ring
those are bonuses that's disgust I took
what it's a bonus that I touched at
least one shower a day and sometimes I
don't feel like I just go in the water
and it's gone
he doesn't feel fresh cuz he says he's a
greasy [ __ ] yeah but I think at
least one shower a day you hate that no
no no I'm just saying that's disgusting
cuz he knows he's greasy we know it
grease and water but if I woulda took a
shower I kept you so quick it's mini
grease this time uses soap I'm just
going to she saw on this side if you're
so high tick what and it's not what
you're saying is I'd save 1.5 hours a
day that's racing yeah
which means you should be taking three
to four showers it does he leave a
residue sutures on his bed yeah there's
like a yellow ring yeah that's from
taking a dry shower though [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] is that CC they know so we got the
beach sections I get out of bed and
stuff and so I was bedridden for like a
full day and so since I couldn't get up
and take a shower they had this like
ribbon it's fancy section big oh okay
yeah I hope that's show with you yes you
had a baby soon that's why sure no it's
not this bottle that it's calling a dry
shower or something like something like
that where you don't need water but it's
those one college no I think mousse okay
yeah weird I get was smelling fantastic
doing a fantastic product I would use
the department yeah I have enough
no no you don't need to just take a
regular shower yeah you guys don't know
you don't do dry shampoo because your
hair shorts are drives really fast if
our who didn't take so long to dry then
we wouldn't need Russia I don't want to
hear women have it so easy
well how does that clean because all
you're doing is smearing more dirt in
your hair
no it just absorbs all the oils so that
it does awardees mattify oh it's magic
Joseph don't question magic dude so it
absorbs it but it stays in your hair but
no magic disappears yeah it's dry I
don't believe in magic that's how they
buy it's like when your skin is dry you
put lotion on it's like yeah but I'm
just spirits smearing more dirt on my
body yeah but you you're after we've
what we're saying like we have to go to
an event right after this other things
like hair perfume are you clean after no
but you know when your hair gets greasy
it's like oh yeah see I get bad too it's
flat so when you put the dry shampoo and
it looks like you just it looks like you
just took a shower
[Music]
[Music]